what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness set up
something that is going to be insanely
huge in the mcu but i think it also sets
something up that fans might not be
expecting but will for sure want to see
take place in the mcu and that is an
avengers versus the x-men storyline now
before you start thinking that this
could be just another civil war
storyline while that could be a
possibility i actually don't think it's
going to be like that at all i think
this is going to be a full-on battle a
full-on war with the avengers and the
x-men and more and to top it all off i
actually think it is going to be a
multiversal war and this will set up the
events that eventually lead us to secret
wars which dr strange and the multiverse
of madness clearly set up and if you've
seen doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness you might know where i'm
going with this but if you haven't we
are going to be talking about some
massive spoilers so this is your spoiler
warning and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so of course
in multiverse of madness we were
introduced to the illuminati which
consisted of professor xavier who of
course was a mutant mr fantastic who of
course is part of the fantastic four and
of course black bolt who is an inhuman
now we don't have any of these people or
groups in the mcu yet that we know of of
course they can't exist and probably do
exist in our universe but i don't think
that the mutants and the fantastic four
in our universe are actually going to be
the problem here i think it's going to
be the groups in the other ultimate
universe which i'll explain in a bit are
actually going to be the problem because
wanda from our universe via dreamwalking
is the one who killed all of the
strongest leaders of the groups in that
universe and i'm guessing that there
probably are going to be some
repercussions for what wanda did and
what dr strange did as well by traveling
to that universe and bringing the
scarlet witch there however let me just
add that i think the introduction of the
mutants in the fantastic four in our
universe earth 616 definitely has to
happen before secret wars but before we
get to secret wars i believe that the
avengers versus the x-men has to happen
but i don't think it's just the x-men
that they're going to have to deal with
i think it's also going to be some of
the remaining members of the fantastic
floor including the wife of reed richard
sue storm the invisible woman her
brother and brother-in-law of reed
richards johnny storm the human torch
reed richards's best friend the thing
plus not to mention his son franklin
richards one of the most powerful
mutants to ever exist an omega level
mutant franklin is literally god tier in
fact at one point in time in the comics
galactus is actually dead but then
franklin revives him and then galactus
becomes his herald also not to mention
another version of franklin richards in
the earth 9997 universe manages to
evolve and actually becomes galactus
himself taking the silver surfer as his
herald so this insanely powerful mutant
is the son of reed richards who was just
murdered by the scarlet witch and here's
the thing in the comics franklin
richards has the power to warp reality
kind of like the scarlet witch he also
has the ability to literally create
universes and even as an infant he was
extremely powerful and managed to save
the fantastic four then and i'm gonna
guess that he's pretty upset that daddy
just died at the hands of a witch and
i'm guessing that the x-men are gonna be
pretty pissed off as well that their
leader professor xavier and the head of
the school that literally takes in
mutants was just killed and black bolt
was the king of the inhumans so i'm
pretty sure a lot of people are gonna be
pissed off there as well now clearly
there was some type of an avengers team
because mordo says that captain peggy
carter was the first avenger so they
might have a group that's going to seek
revenge too they know that the scarlet
witch didn't die and they probably don't
want to risk her being alive in the
multiverse where she can kind of do
whatever she wants plus not to mention
they might think that our universe earth
616 might be a threat to them since it
essentially already was and it could
threaten their universe still with an
incursion so i think they might take
action against our universe and the
heroes who right now aren't exactly the
avengers team but hey they'll have to
assemble and here's where i think we're
going to be getting the avengers versus
the x-men the fantastic four the
inhumans and whoever else might want to
seek revenge but it might not even be
about revenge or vengeance they might
just want to take out the scarlet witch
and the scarlet witch's reality warping
powers going up against franklin
richard's reality warping powers i think
will definitely ramp up the dangers of
an incursion occurring and i do think
that that's all going to take place
because that is exactly how secret wars
happens in the comics in the comics
incursion happens between the earth 616
universe and the ultimate universe and
if you noticed in the illuminati scene
where the illuminati was telling doctor
strange the truth they say that his
ultimate self is the one that formed the
illuminati in the first place so this
actually could be the so-called ultimate
universe now obviously things are a
little bit different from the comics but
since doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness focuses on this universe and
the illuminati and the teams of this
universe and not to mention the threat
of incursion i do believe that this is
the universe that our earth will
eventually collide with with an
incursion and this will set up the
events of secret wars which will in turn
cause everybody to have to work together
now it is worth noting that franklin
richards in the comics is the one to
restore the multiverse and i think it
was very very specific of the movie and
they made it a point to mention that
reed richard had kids and a wife that
was still alive marvel is pretty
intentional with everything they do and
since they introduced the fantastic four
i think this was pretty intentional now
i've seen a lot of talk online about
maybe the beyonder galactus or another
huge villain appearing to be the main
villain of secret wars since that's how
it was in the comics with specific talk
about god emperor doom and while i do
think that he is going to be introduced
into the mcu sometime soon because the
fantastic four are coming i don't
believe that he actually has to be in
the mcu for secret wars to happen
remember the movies don't copy the
comics page for page they take general
stories or some ideas for stories and
they create movies that are amazing so
don't expect a shot for shot secret wars
just like infinity ward didn't have the
x-men or the fantastic four in it either
so everybody's been wondering who was
gonna be the villain but marvel has
already set up the villain kang kang has
already literally mentioned the war
between different universes he literally
says multiversal war and he says that
the multiversal war was between his
variants his variants fighting each
other so we already know that king and
many different versions of him want to
rule the multiverse and as we saw at the
end of loki the sacred timeline is no
more a bunch of different branch
timelines have been created and that
means that a bunch of different kangs
are coming so as far as who the villain
of secret wars is going to be i believe
that we actually already have our
villain he's set up already kang the
conqueror a true king the conqueror not
he who remains not the same person we
met at the end of loki because as he
explains if you think he's evil wait
till you see his variants so king the
conqueror is being introduced in ant-man
and the wasp quantomania where i assume
they will explore more of the multiverse
and the quantum realm and i think in
this movie we're going to see the
groundwork being laid for secret wars to
actually happen it's already been
happening we literally heard about
incursion and multiverse of madness and
how it's a big big threat universe is
colliding and now we have a villain
coming that wants to rule the entire
multiverse and it's gonna take the
heroes coming together from different
universes to defeat him a multiversal
threat takes a multiversal team let's
just hope that all the stuff that goes
down between them the avengers versus
the x-men gets cleared up so they can
get together to take on kang the
conqueror and in the meantime let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below would you like to
see an avengers versus the x-men and
other groups movie and let me know how
excited you are for secret wars don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on the latest news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof